the Joe Rogan experience yeah you don't
do you know who the hodgetwins are yes
yeah they do you know like yeah they
have they have a [ __ ] there's a they
were reading an article about men
getting pregnant like that women aren't
the only ones you can get pregnant no
because the way they talk you know you
know the way they talk about their big
old Jack dudes you know and I'm on the
podcast they're kind of you yeah and
they get seriously amped up but they
were talking about busted and not inside
dudes asked can I get them pregnant
about how you go in that man's anus and
there's family like yeah they talked
[ __ ] like Jews dude because people
are saying super crazy [ __ ] that's not
that's a crazy yes yes yes yes this is a
real argument you know Yale started
putting tampons dispensers get the [ __ ]
in the men's room because they said not
everyone who men straights is a woman hi
my son welcome to the upside-down world
did you ever uh did you ever watch
stranger things do comes to this what
you were watch stranger things like yeah
look we're in the world is upside down
right now that's what's happening so
just flip it over to the other side
people are getting there so progressive
they're literally denying science for
for feelings do you feel like a woman
then you're a woman yeah [ __ ] I identify
as a woman do you feel like a man well
then you're a man that is amazing
man bro congratulations you're gonna
make the best mom dad whatever the [ __ ]
whatever dad mom these dudes are coming
in dudes a suspect
it's a funny it's a funny little thing
that they did did you find it that's
looking for it and they may I still
motocross nothing else they just talked
about what you're just talking they're
all over YouTube yeah what is this meet
the formally transgender man and now
identifies as a genderless alien oh yeah
I seen that do we show that guy before
his surgery in a surgery destruction
Allen I don't give a [ __ ] just don't
force it on me that I have to if I [ __ ]
him call you a hand yeah I see
congratulations to them yeah their
graduations you go you've made it yeah
a lot of people want to be special but
they don't want to work for it and the
problem with that is you get that kind
of [ __ ] you get people that are
pretending to be something super special
to get attention so they get attention
and you're not doing anything and
there's nothing there you know what I
really love I had Eddie Izzard on who's
probably one of the most famous
transgender people ever and just gently
I saw your picture
just decided that's what he likes and
once you get past that and just talk to
him
he's amazing humans a human man he's
amazing I don't care what I care is when
you say crazy things like men can get
pregnant that's insane that's not real
have yet custody on the Navy side you
know and was run for governor I don't
know what she's doing now but we count I
went to lunch with her afterwards normal
[ __ ] man normal also talks like like
like you might go when you were in
battle this and just talks like like a
[ __ ] human like I give a [ __ ] yeah
all right you want to wear a dress yeah
everyone's looking at you because you
got the physique of me and you got a
[ __ ] miniskirt on all right whatever
who cares you give the [ __ ] once you get
used to it
like you're used to the way people dress
period yes you used to everything you
know it's just nonsense
it's nonsense like I don't care as long
as you're not hurting me yeah we're
hurting someone else I don't wash in it
I don't care
don't push it off Eddie Izzard say what
like he always felt like that this is a
man can that babies now play this can we
play it or we get pulled will probably
its own Twitter will get pulled no no no
no stairs you'll hear the volume hear
the audio no we'll just tell people what
is the it just says men can have babies
now and it's on I couldn't find out can
we hear it really broke copyright laws
no joke I don't
doesn't matter we'd have to edit it out
later it's just looked YouTube's in a
weird place right now in terms of
copyright and we've gotten claims on us
for watching something on a screen in
the background like you see a picture in
a picture and you you don't even hear it
and they want all the ad revenue for the
entire show how about the UH cheese
ridiculous where how about that when the
the combine guy were talking about his
dick that got flagged when I was like eh
she's dick popped out of tact for nudity
yeah come on come on
it's [ __ ] dick you like you you got
that pop down and you have to pause it
and just go frame-by-frame we go is that
the days kind of pixelated okay Thunder
for half a second don't even know what
you're looking at if I don't tell you
[Applause]